the city of tucson arizona has fired a
police officer who shot and killed a man
who was sitting in a moving electric
scooter
newly released video from monday night
shows that ryan remington confronted a
suspected shoplifter before firing nine
shots the police chief says that
remington's actions were wrong our
national correspondent jericho duncan
has more on this story we have to warn
you that the video and some of the
details here are very disturbing
i have a male suspect that just
shoplifted back
you're looking at surveillance video
from a tucson walmart it shows former
police officer ryan remington and a
walmart employee they're slowly trailing
61-year-old richard lee richards through
a parking lot while he's in a mobility
scooter white male
flannel t-shirt
white hat police say an employee told
remington who was off duty and working
security at the store that richard stole
a tool box remington asked richards for
a receipt but richards allegedly
brandished a knife and continued toward
another store according to the walmart
employee mr richard said
if you want me to put down the knife
you're going to have to shoot me
another officer arrived as richards made
his way to the entrance of a lowe's
hardware store remington is heard asking
richards to stop
moments later remington opened fire
nine rounds hitting richards before he
fell to the ground
footage from the security camera shows
remington using handcuffs on richards
right after the shooting officers
rendered medical care but a short time
later
mr richards was declared dead tucson
police chief chris magnus condemned
remington's actions in a news conference
tuesday his use of deadly force in this
incident is a clear violation of
department policy and directly
contradicts
multiple aspects of our use of force and
training we are going to take our time
and actually look at everything which
attorney mike story is representing
remington these were cut and pasted
videos which showed about 20 percent of
what actually happened last night
story also said his client's close
proximity to richards did not allow the
officer to safely deploy his taser in a
statement released tuesday tucson mayor
regina romero called the shooting
unconscionable and indefensible the case
is now under investigation by the pima
county attorney's office i think a lot
of people look at that video and they
think well he's in a wheelchair how is
he an imminent threat but of course all
of this will will play out as it should
with the justice system and the
attorney's office the county attorney i
love the attorney saying look you've
only seen 20 of the video i'd like to
see the rest of the video that makes it
okay to do to respond the way that he
did yeah right you're in a knife and
you're you're sitting down
i have uh friends and family that are
police officers yeah um so when i see
this my emotions are quick to race but
i'm slow to judge right but when i see
the video it's hard for me not to think
about two things de-escalation yes and
then excessive force
and it just seems like
here's another situation where a police
officer
just went too far i'm not saying i know
all the details but just at first sight
i never understand to your point about
nine shots to someone who is in a riding
scooter yeah with a knife not a gun
and it's he shot nine times i'll never
understand it's under investigation so
there could be possible charges here you
can see yep eureka thank you so much